we're now doing something that I have
wanted to do for like I don't know your
entire life thank you since you guys did
you gotta know Tirico and running back
for the Chicago Bears you definitely
understand now that your last name Cohen
when I first saw that I went holy crap
we have a Jewish running back in the NFL
and you've heard this a lot I imagine oh
yeah definitely all in my Twitter
mitches like what were people saying to
you they just dear me if they hire you
Jews and you respond with I didn't
respond all the time but I was minding
like one person would just say no sadly
no sadly but I also want to talk
football with you you've been truly a
revelation I think for the Bears where
we were saying you were the best wide
receiver on the team last year and you
play running back did you ever think you
would be used at such a like a receiver
capacity I was thinking about it I knew
I had about to do it but uh I played
mainly running back in college like I
didn't line up ever see that all right
right and I only had a hundred
receptions like though I'm a whole
career yeah so you know it's a big
transition to just being and receiving
back now and lining up in this lot but
uh I did it a lot you know any 7:07 sure
I never play running back always want to
be receiver and you did something before
the draft that I thought was a wonderful
idea the video of him catching the ball
while doing a backflip yes oh yeah that
was amazing I used it as a marketing
tool yes
did it improve your stock like what
changed after that happened I feel like
it did they put my name out there and
then people have to see like Kenny's got
really played football the DNA look me
up
look at my highlighting him blow he
can't play yeah so then that helped me
out so I'm always amazed you could walk
around New York City
you could be on someone's fantasy team
and they're not gonna recognize ya they
wouldn't even know me I didn't go
anywhere basically is that great or do
you want to be moms no oh you like to do
be able to go to Walmart you know just
nice that's the perk cuz you're in a
Walmart and not being know
doesn't man so we were trying to come up
with nicknames for you and Jordan Howard
because I think thunder and lightning
anytime there's a power back and a seat
back yeah it's annoying yeah so we had a
few one of them was the Hebrew and the
hammer yeah not bad
the other one was and we also had the
Mensch and the bench like he's doing a
bench press the [ __ ] Wow Oh cuz they
need me sitting on the baby there's this
one guy in your team that just recently
came kind of a big deal I mean how were
you guys when you heard like wait Khalil
Mac might be coming to our defense like
what did that do in the locker room when
you first heard that little rumor out
there oh you know we just thinking like
it's over now our defense was already
right on top defense in the ad a piece
like Khalil man it's crazy
top five got in the field last year yeah
you know for me I just wanted to see how
that looks in person you know a person
that's great and position
you know he's rip ready he put like 5%
body fat
tell me how much he weighs that's crazy
yes and he gets all his works done in
the weight room like push-ups to failure
right and like he's not gonna fail so
he's gonna be in how many shots are we
talking I mean it takes for you to fail
that's what he's done so he's going like
over a hundred yeah probably
what does that do to a team when you get
a guy and he comes in and he even
surpasses your expectations and the
expectations were super high it laid the
blueprint for us I feel like you see
what he does and you know how's point
paying off on the field and you want to
do the exact same thing so you know you
just follow along and have been the
first game the Packers first half yeah
he rips the ball away against Aaron
Rodgers a guy you like what was that
experience everybody side on what you're
saying like oh that's how you
[Laughter]